You may never get high blood pressure
after watching this video. The most
important thing to know about blood
pressure is that it is a symptom. It's
not a root cause. And in this video,
we're going to talk about the root
causes because the problem with
hypertension is that 95% of it is
classified as something called essential
high blood pressure, which basically
means they don't really know what causes
it. It might be caused by, you know,
genetics or lifestyle. We don't know.
But if you lose weight and reduce your
salt and you exercise and you stop
smoking and you stop drinking, it might
go away. There's also a lot of people
who don't exercise and they don't have
high blood pressure. And there's a large
group of people who consume a lot of
salt and they don't have high blood
pressure. And when someone is put on
hypertensive medication, 20% of the time
it doesn't work. Now, why wouldn't that
work? Because they're treating the
symptom. They're not fixing the cause.
Anytime you treat the symptom without
fixing the root cause, you camouflage
the problem. it continues. Now, if you
have high blood pressure, I'm not
telling you to come off your medication
without your doctor's consent, but I
want to give you some really important
information that will help you get to
the root of this problem. All right, now
let's get into the root causes. Okay,
let's start with the big one. Vitamin D
deficiency. There is a hormone system
called the water pressure control
system. When this system gets triggered
and it goes up, there is a potent vasoc
constriction going on in your arteries.
Basically, there's a squeezing of the
arteries and the pressure is going to go
up. That is triggered by low vitamin D.
This system being high also causes a
massive retention of sodium. Wherever
the sodium goes, the water goes. More
sodium, more water, more pressure. This
is why there's a big push to get
everyone with high blood pressure off of
sodium or on a low sodium diet. They
would be much better off giving the
person vitamin D and also increasing
their potassium. The more potassium you
have, the more sodium you could have.
Potassium protects you against the
excess amount of sodium. People that are
salt sensitive are really potassium
deficient. And unfortunately, the
majority of population doesn't get
enough potassium because you need so
much. You need like 4700
milligrams every single day. No one's
getting that much. And also look at how
many people are deficient in vitamin D.
It's just off the charts. Another
interesting point about this is that
your risk of high blood pressure goes up
during the winter. Why is that? The way
the sun is angled at the earth, there's
just not enough UV radiation to create
enough vitamin D in our skin. And then
we have this other very important
factor. The darker your skin, the more
you're at risk for high blood pressure.
On average, if you have dark skin, your
risk for high blood pressure goes up by
2x. Why does this happen? Because
melanin in your skin is a pigment and it
acts as a sunscreen. It it blocks you of
ultraviolet radiation making it very
difficult to make vitamin D. This is why
the darker your skin, the more vitamin D
you need to take or the more sun
exposure you need to have. Then you get
into the genetic high blood pressure
situation. Well, that's usually
associated with a genetic problem with
vitamin D, which is interesting. There's
a super high percentage of people that
have a genetic problem with vitamin D
that can't absorb vitamin D that well
and they need a lot more vitamin D. So,
I've even questioned, do we really have
a genetic blood pressure problem or do
we have a genetic problem with vitamin D
that's causing the high blood pressure?
I mentioned that 95% of all blood
pressure problems are essential, which
means they're unknown cause. So, it
could be lifestyle, it could be genetic,
they don't know. They just throw all
these lifestyle things in a box and you
know we just don't know. But in the
meantime, keep taking medication because
until we find out a cause, we need to
keep that pressure low. Then we have
this insulin resistant connection. If
you consume a lot of carbs or you're
eating a lot of snacks, you develop this
condition called insulin resistance. And
this is a precursor for high blood
glucose. And it is the root cause of a
fatty liver. high blood pressure, high
cholesterol, belly fat, high glucose,
it's all just insulin resistance. If
you're low in vitamin D, your risk for
getting this goes high. So, that could
be one mechanism why some people that
are obese develop hypertension because
the obesity is diluting the vitamin D
and either triggering insulin resistance
or just causing high blood pressure
directly. Vitamin D depends on
magnesium. Magnesium is essential for
vitamin D to work. So these go hand in
hand. So this is why I put vitamin D,
magnesium, and potassium. Okay, those
three right there. Let's look at another
connection between vitamin D and soft
tissue calcium. Now you have this
situation where if there's too much
calcium in the arteries, your arteries
can get stiff and actually your blood
pressure can go up from there. And if
you watch some of my other videos, I
recommend taking vitamin K2 to direct
the calcium into the bone or the teeth
and out of the soft tissues. And there's
actually even a test called the coronary
artery calcification test, which is a
really good indicator or a predictor of
all cause mortality. This is why people
with cramps at night or just leg cramps
or feet cramps really they need more
magnesium. Why? Magnesium prevents the
calcium from building up in the tissues.
Also think about women who are
postmenopausal that take calcium
supplements. Their risk for heart attack
goes up. Why? Because you're dumping all
this calcium. I mean, some women are
taking like 1,200 or 1,500 milligrams of
calcium every single day. And sometimes
they even take it with vitamin D.
They're still at risk for heart
problems. Why? Because they're deficient
in magnesium. Magnesium keeps the
calcium from getting too high and
forming clots. That's right. Too much
clotting or a thrombosis they call it
could be coming from too much calcium.
Also arrhythmias can also be coming from
too much calcium. And guess what?
Magnesium is the antidote to preventing
building up in the arteries, heart
attacks, all sorts of things. And let's
just talk about two medications they use
for high blood pressure. Calcium channel
blockers, which by the way, magnesium is
a natural calcium channel blocker, but
you can't patent it. So they use a
medication. Then you also have something
else called beta blockers. Beta blockers
block adrenaline. Okay? So if there's
too much adrenaline in the body, your
blood pressure will go up as well. And
take a wild guess what a natural beta
blocker is. Not just magnesium, but
vitamin D. Both of these will naturally
decrease adrenaline. Now let's roll into
the four things I recommend to correct
the problem if you have high blood
pressure. Okay. Vitamin D. So, I would
take 10,000 IUs every single day. But if
you're trying to correct high blood
pressure, take 20,000 or even a little
bit more. Now, if you have any thought
in your mind that 20,000 IUs is toxic.
Being on the sun for about 40 minutes
will give you 20,000 IUs of vitamin D3.
So, 20,000 is not a toxic level. In
fact, this is really like half of one
milligram of vitamin D3. Magnesium, very
underrated, but it's very important. I
would recommend taking magnesium
glycinate. You can get a good amount of
magnesium from pumpkin seeds, sunflower
seeds, spinach, other leafy greens,
almonds, and even chocolate. Just make
sure you don't have the chocolate with a
lot of sugar. Magnesium allows vitamin D
to work. These two go hand in hand. Then
I recommend going on a low carb diet
because at the root of high blood
pressure, metabolic syndrome, heart
disease is too many carbs and consuming
too much sugar and starch depletes you
of vitamin D, magnesium and potassium.
Okay, so you need to do that. Also,
potassium is very very important. You
can get this from an electrolyte powder.
I would recommend taking a high quality
electrolyte powder that has about a,000
milligrams of potassium with other
electrolytes. But you can also get
potassium from greens, but you have to
consume a very large salad every single
day. But the greens will also give you
magnesium. Now, to get more details on
this low carb diet, you should go to
this video right here.